hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to security breach ruin
we are going back in brand new we're
gonna see all the things that I missed
oh my God I missed so much stuff but
we're also going to get it absolutely
everything that's right we're going back
to the very beginning to get every
single collectible that we missed and
complete all the secret objectives to
get the true ending to this game of
which I'm sure there is and I will not
be a sway so we got multiple things on
our list we've got the wet floor signs
because it was a bug and I wasn't able
to get it because I confirmed like it
confirmed with everyone else was saying
that they were running into the same
problem where they didn't get in the
same game and going back shut up whereby
going back that one in the room I was
right I did not get that one that was a
bug so we're going back to the beginning
to get all of the wet floor signs
because that would be more efficient but
also to get all of the other things in
this game that are lurking beneath the
surface your heart out Matt Pat I'm
coming for you well I'm not really I
already beat you there I'm assuming
definitely so there's a few things that
we discovered throughout our last
experiences and I won't recap everything
and I'm not going to do a full
playthrough obviously I'm going to jump
ahead in time to get through these
places but just to recap of what we did
not see we did not see what the wet
floor signs give you and we did not see
what the arcade games give you now I'm
not going to beat the arcade games just
yet there are going to be some things
that I'm going to need to go back
because I don't have time right now to
get them but I will do I know there's
got there there's Monty and then there's
chica I don't know if there's a Freddy
arcade game lurking around there
somewhere but there was the Hall of
arcade games and also there was the
overturned arcade game in Vanny's office
more likely than not there probably is
well I guess there wasn't a Roxy arcade
game either I don't even remember if
there was in the main game either way
we're gonna go get the Collectibles I do
have a list I'm not pulling this all out
of my head we saw a few Secrets already
but that doesn't mean that we're going
to be able to just sail our way to them
but I'm gonna guide you through this
experience
I'm gonna guide you through this
experience and we're going to get
through here together what happens if I
go around
useless okay so the first collectible is
actually something that we got before
it's right over here wall bam but I
can't believe that I didn't get a single
real world collectible until the very
very end of my official playthrough that
is so sad and extremely pathetic but the
other thing that we haven't touched on
is the security camera the thing at the
end of the hallway when I was going
through and I was looping a whole bunch
you
first one okay this is the first one and
I'm not gonna bring the game back just
looking at these even though they
very satisfying to uh deactivate I saw
this room that Dory was blocked at the
end I saw something at the very end of
the hallway
it actually opened up and that means
that that does apply to something and
I'm almost positive that that is at the
very end of the game I'm it must have
something to do with that chase sequence
at the end because I believe there was a
room there was a room that had one door
open but not all of them so I'm thinking
that if you go in here and what I'm
talking about if you don't remember I'm
Auntie how you doing and I know there's
an arcade cabinet here but I'll get to
it in a moment I'm pretty sure there's
probably going to be something if you
beat it but I have no idea but look at
this right here bam this opens door
behind it as I go through this I'm going
to show you where these are but I don't
know where all of them are I think I
inadvertently got them last time I was
doing this but this is the first one
from the very first camera system this
is part of it and this clearly is
pointed at the basement somewhere and
this clearly is something to do with the
ending
something
oh crap I almost missed one okay hold on
no
oh did I already
oh you cannot
why do they do this or they just prevent
you from going back clearly I should be
able to jump up on this and just go back
what is the point of not being able to
go back because this is just oh man that
one is gotta be the worst to miss
because it's right
I have to play from the beginning
I'm fine
I'm good
all right here's the deal here's the
deal this is how smart I am I knew that
I could miss that one because I was
going to come back anyway because I was
not going to get bogged down with golf
right now even though I could even
though I could but because I have to
come back anyway and the only way to get
that one is to go back from the
beginning again so I can get that other
collectible so then that's exactly what
I'll do we're gonna get to it guys
we're gonna get to it
don't you worry
we're gonna get to it you know what else
we're gonna get to this this is the next
collectible
don't matter I'll be back so floor signs
we're here for the floor signs we're
gonna get
I didn't know if you knew about this but
if you don't get the dude this happens
foreign
man Gregory you're really good at
talking uh in multiple voices all at the
same time it's quite a skill you got
there how
good thing I got all of them
they don't have to worry about missing
any
I sure hope that the secret ending or
whatever the true ending is it doesn't
rely on me having all those that would
be a shame oh
now it comes a real test if this thing's
deactivated when I get into this next
area I'm gonna be extremely pissed I'll
be unbelievable chaos
next one's back here
yay
yippee good thing I've gotten everything
and I haven't missed anything
yeah there you are there you are Hi how
are you doing buddy oh good to see you
oh were you were you preemptively
deactivated oh will you just we're just
trying to pretend to be deactivated to
not allow me to enter this tube and then
deactivate you oh you're missing out
because actually it was me that was
going to the Eggman anyway it's time to
go to bed now yeah extreme
what
[Music]
oh I'm sorry I'm sorry
I can't get out
what what uh uh don't kill me do not do
don't I gotta get this collectible and
then I gotta get out of here
all right
we did it
good for us well that's a proof of
concept because now I know that I can go
through this game and do everything else
and I can get all of the floor signs and
I haven't missed any because I know I
missed one
did I get the one behind the forklift
I definitely
I definitely got it right
I wouldn't have not
gotten it
next one's back here
yay
yippee good thing I've got
it
I got it
I got it I got it
definitely you know you don't even need
to say it all right you don't need to
say nobody needs to say anything now
about whether I got it or not no one
needs to say anything because I know I
got it because I would have gotten it I
remember getting it and I'm not
confusing these memories of me getting
it with anything else of me not getting
it therefore I can go forward with
confidence that I got it which I did
oh whoop
that was the first real uh second it was
the second one
and I slipped be careful
[Music]
hey look at that
ain't that cool that's real cool
there it is there's another one right
there boom open I think it's a series of
doors that just continue down until
something at the end is open because I
think when I was doing the uh looking
for the wet floor signs I think I opened
them I think I saw
what's at the end and what's at the end
must be something that changes the end
of the game
got everything here we got everything in
the last one which means that we're good
to go okay supposedly
ah wow that is right there wow that is
right there huh
oh wow a comic page how many of those do
I have now
I've got two
scary Five
and then seven should be an artist when
he grows up should be should be so now
we get to do something that is important
apparently we go in here we you remember
this you remember this yeah
well this exists
and we're gonna beat it
we're gonna do whatever it takes to beat
it all right almost there almost there
it's Gotta uh it's gonna pop any minute
now there we go way
yeah I did it I made the best
I'm at the best
oh okay I was about to say
I was about to say if I didn't actually
get that hey I got chica's voice box
okay so that's nice
um so when
I know exactly when there's another part
in Roxy's Raceway not Racers that chica
just goes and lays down in the bathroom
for some reason and I thought that was
peculiar because I died to her when that
occurred but I didn't know why I didn't
know why it was happening I bet that's
when I use it okay hold on I should have
gotten this before but there's actually
a real present
right behind that one node it's amazing
how these real ones were like right in
front of my eyes they weren't even that
well hidden this one even has a light on
it and yeah because I didn't know what I
was looking for
I didn't know I could even get him I
didn't even know it was a thing I didn't
even know it was a possibility but alas
please don't kill me
oh boy
I would love to take this off also was
there a zoom out on that one I think
there might have been I have no idea I'm
gonna die I honestly this is for the
best because I think there might have
been a zoom there hello
good bag of trash that's what's strange
like that
there was there was a zoom out there ah
I'm glad that I looked for that because
wow
oh
I think I'm in trouble
oh wait but I I oh buddy
so I gotta make sure I zoom out on the
thing again I can't forget that that
actually is a thing
I didn't do the zoom out ah frick the
one thing I said to do God
Frick God the one thing I said to do
[Music]
oh
God I said make sure to do the oh and
then I didn't do it just another thing
I'll go back and do so long as I can
actually remember all the things that I
didn't do because my Flawless
performance I needed to add a little
drama into this that's what it is I'm
just really trying to milk this content
so I'm trying to stretch it out I'm
intentionally doing it so you can all be
very old
in actuality I am better than that
I hate
I'll just come back
again anyway we have something else
important to know about this which is
the voice box
am I really doing this I don't know
apparently
Rose
that should do it
okay I did that
and I'm sure that has some kind of a
repercussion down the road I just don't
know what
that is shockingly we're almost there I
definitely got all of them
I definitely didn't miss any I wonder if
there's something to do with this too
because it is strange that you can go
through this whole thing
and get to the front of the line here
and get it's closed one thing I'll say
about this and I don't know where people
are at in terms of digging up all the
secrets there is a difference here this
staff bot is red I've never seen a red
staff bot before maybe I have but this
that bot is red
I don't know what that means
you know um this is very funny I didn't
get it at first but don't lose your head
in it's Freddy
okay around the corner to the left oh
nope not there but what about over here
ah that seems so obvious now
that seems so obvious why it's pretty so
worried
oh no oh no
yeah yeah yeah so there's still the bug
problem
of dying here because you're still there
okay goodbye
[Music]
how did people not find that in play
testing that's what I want to know I
mean I know that like things get
overlooked all the time there's always
going to be some bugs but I'm like how
did that how'd that's get how'd that get
by so
apparently
my God
how did I miss that
how I don't understand
uh uh I got this before this is comic
page one which is great good to know and
then there's another fun room I don't
know if I showed you guys this one but
uh this one's fun
uh very fun great stuff thank you for
the nightmares all right guys
um it's Moment of Truth of uh whether or
not I actually got that one all the way
in chapter two or not behind the
forklift
um
it would be really something if I didn't
you know what I mean it would be really
something
but uh here's the moment you know I got
golden Bonnie right here that's
like
You're Just Pizza all right
I've been if I didn't get that one
because it was literally right then and
there and if I didn't get it it would
have been just like right in front of my
face
I
all right you know what my favorite
chapter is
chapter two I just freely feel like
playing that one again I'm just like
yeah oh
right yeah because I missed a
collectible in
chapter one that's not what I'm here for
that's not what I'm here for I gotta go
chapter two
if I get in there and the one behind the
thing is deactivated oh
oh it's gonna be a bad time
boy
[Music]
so if this one if I did get this one
which one did I not get
oh
my God
what I went through the whole game to
make sure that I got every one of them
which one did I miss
so don't
so dumb why do I have to do this again
why is this my life I could go back to
chapter five double check that I got
things there but it's like
you get I got both the ones at the
staircases I could go back and look at
the camera again because I missed that
uh I don't want to do this again
there now that's open there's one more
door back there so there must be
something else to get okay I got both of
those did I not get the one in the
bathroom over there there's one in the
bathroom to the right here
I know I died a few times but did I get
a mix-up oh
I don't think I got anything mixed up
those two are both deactivated over
there
that's deactivated I really don't know
where this would be well you know I
gotta go back to chapter one anyway to
get that other thing that I got so I
might as well just go back to chapter
one
do that again
it's
right here
the only one I'm checking here is number
two the second of the the web floor
signs because I do see a world where I
was so confident in that other section
that I just blasted right by it for some
reason not sure why
oh oh there we go
there we go so he repeat encounters
count apparently because that looks open
that looks open as hell okay so that
that's definitely open
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna beat the
golf game right now I'll come back for
that I know I said I was gonna come back
for it there but I meant later meant
later
then later
nope this one is done too
great I did that
I did all of these that's the thing I
did all of these I made sure I've been
doing them so many times that I wouldn't
have missed any
activated all these are deactivated
every single one of these
is deactivated
man
I can't believe I'm saying this but the
only one that I could have possibly
missed would have been chapter two by
that arcade but the thing is if I did
miss it that is the one that bugs out so
if I go in there and it's deactivated
I'm Not Really Gonna know if it's bugged
or not and then what I have to go
through the whole thing again I was so
sure that it was the one behind the
forklift that I didn't get but
I swear if it's down to that same one
again I don't know what I'm gonna do I I
legitimately don't know what I'm gonna
do because
literally when I was there I deactivated
it unless
I got jump scared to the point where I
let go of the button and then assumed
that it was all good I could see that
happening but also I'd be real upset
about it
then which one is it when am I gonna not
waste my time
I've
I've done them all I've
I've done them all
there isn't one that I've missed
but you know what I got a good feeling
that I know how to make this a reality
all right so I gotta I gotta admit
something to you guys this was a joint
effort to get here I had to pull in all
the best favors that I could and
everyone flocked of course because they
were like we want to help you get this
obviously your game is bugged and you
would have you would have gotten world
first about this but you know I had to
do this so it's actually uh me and doco
we got together we figured it out we
hacked the game code together 50 50 it
was mostly me but we together came
together and we're here ready live to
bring you this live reaction of what the
wet floor signs are gonna bring I was
just looking for the pack patents
everywhere all right collection all the
pack Parts Glam Rock Bonnie is behind
this wall guys and what's supposed to
happen when you collect all the Pop pots
it's a pop pot should be here the last
one that you deactivate and then this
area here opens up to go and see Glam
Rock Bonnie but unfortunately there's a
book right now where doesn't spawn here
okay guys so let's pretend that we did
deactivate the pat pat there and we're
going through where it opens up walk
through yeah this is us walking through
uh my hacks guys thank you so much for
doing this it's absolutely insane he
likes to call me by weird names
sometimes
and he
and he were in this is nuts
so cool this is so cool I know it's the
official animatronic body he looks so
cool he looks like he's dead he
literally
yeah in a minute yeah
yeah I don't know why you call it a Pat
Pat this is where glamor Bonnie got
murdered by Monty yeah he got murdered
I remember saying it at least twice
can we see Glam Rock Bonnie yeah he's
quoting me and as soon as rowing got
revealed everybody was saying that we
really hope to see Glam Rock Bonnie I
know I was telling you that I was ready
a really cool Easter egg collecting all
the cleaning Bots throughout the game
eventually leads you to this scene of
yeah glamor bunnies yeah it does
yeah all of these are here surrounding
him and if you look closely
Bonnie's eyes are active right now they
are they are active same similar color
now look what happens when we deactivate
him
yeah so yeah
noise the Glam Rock bodies eyes have
been shut off exactly
Dory of Glam Rock Bonnie giving Monty
his guitar you know passing the guitar
to Monty for him to be in the band uh
bullcrap guys that's just a story it's
bull crap it's just a story Monty
murdered Barney sorry about Monty
destroying Glam Rock Bonnie exactly
that's just a made-up story he's made up
guys but made up their entertainment
just yeah to explain what happened with
Glam Rock Bonnie Glam Rock bunnies left
the band
Monty to be the performer never happened
don't believe it that's Scott's lies a
strange detail of this so it looks like
Monty
shoved Bonnie onto the wall yeah ripped
his stomach open you can see Monty's
claw here fully ripped his stomach open
right and that's not the worst part
about it you can see here there's a
split bowling ball but what he's doing
is ripped Bonnie apart maybe
what I think happened
what I think happens
okay doco I'd like to speak this is
supposed to be a Duo thing here you know
50 50. and you're not really doing 50.
so here's what I think actually happened
is Bonnie was practicing some sick
bowling tricks he was flinging a bowling
ball it bounced off the wall hence the
crack hit him right in the face and then
exploded into shrapnel tearing his
insides apart and so what happened was
there was so much blood that when Monty
arrived on the scene his hair actually
wasn't red before that
doco please please please
it's my turn to talk
more like taco am I right when Monty
arrived his hair wasn't actually red he
slipped and fell in the blood of
Bonnie's blood and he was like
Eddie was so freaked out by it he was
but then he remembered Safety First pla
placed all the wet floor signs not pot
pots
British so there was so much blood he
was so responsible he kept it from all
of the other members of the bands who
would have been devastated because it
was performance night and if it was
performance and they found out the body
died there never would have been able to
do a show you know the show must go on
and Monty was a hero he placed the signs
and then placed him throughout the whole
thing leveling up the standard of safety
of the entire Mega Pizza Plex and
therefore he's actually the hero Bonnie
it was just clumsy anyway and then we
killed him and then we murdered him
because that was very clear his lights
were on and then they're off and we did
that so we murdered him that's a moral
of the story all right now you can
finish it up doctor really long time the
next question is why the papasia and why
did you climb Rock Bonnie have the
glowing noise I listen I just explained
this to you you're really good at
freezing your face like that but I just
explained this to you if you're just
gonna ignore me then I'm not gonna do
these code streams with you anymore okay
with the pop parts and as soon as we do
motivated them all why did gun Rock
Bonnie shut down I I told you would they
we killed them how more clear can I make
this you know I'm not I'm gonna stop
collabing with you if you keep shutting
down my opinions like this it's just
it's not respect do you know about
respect because I know about respect
it's a word okay look it up Bonnie was
using his amount of energy the last
source of power in his system to to
reach out to the pat Pats as a
distressed signal for help the other
option is that the pat Pats knew about
Glam Rock Bonnie and that's why they're
here they're trying to clean up the mess
or alert the staff about this incident
what's happened because nobody works
here anymore no nobody's found this out
there you go guys all right so yeah
that's a really good theory yeah really
believable uh except Marty has red hair
blood slippery I should know look just
shout out my channel and just let's go
come on let's just wrap it up man it was
all Monty Monty was jealous
jealous it's one man bamdeep is on his
own Monty was the hero Monty might have
been a hero that's also equally valid
yeah he was joint man because he was
talented he's got a mind of his own we
know he's aggressive
we are who we are because of our
programming you know but there's nature
versus nurture so that was part of the
band oh yeah he is part of the band
that's kind of important to remember
aggressive
yeah distress call yeah now sure use the
possessed children inside of all the pat
Pats to be able to send a distress call
that's not that's not messed up that's
not crazy but that's what I think that's
what what you think uh-huh yellow yeah
his eyes were yellow you know kind of
like uh demons I really do wish that we
actually spoke to Glam Rock Bonnie yeah
wouldn't that be great why don't you
break out your Ouija board because he's
dead cause we killed them he's commuting
with uh the wet floor signs maybe you
can communicate with us before we smash
the bowling ball into his soul to get
ready
hold on and I'll see you all next time
hold on everyone is
all right well okay all right you know
what hey you know if he's not gonna
shout out my channel I'm not going to
shout out his channel either this is
ridiculous we found this together we
found this together and you're just
uses it for that that's my theory my
theory is the valid Theory Matt Pat can
suck an egg he doesn't know anything
about Five Nights at Freddy's because I
don't know whatever he knows but I know
that he doesn't know the right things
because that's what everyone else says
and what I say goes with what everyone
else says goes and what I say is that
Monty is a saint and you guys should
respect the name and I think Glam Rock
Bonnie was ready to kill again and I say
again and you better believe me I know
it's again so it's a good thing he was
put down before it got a little out of
hand anyway so that's that that's where
all that led few bugs but then again
that's what I do I find the bugs thank
you everybody so much for watching in
the next episode we're going to see
where those security cameras lead and
then we're gonna get to the bottom of
this me I say we I mean me I'm gonna get
to the bottom of this because nobody
else can be trusted to do so all right
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]